blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription by going to blinkist.com
david pakman all right let's start with
something positive we have genuinely
better and better looking covet updates
over the last few weeks globally and in
the united states and today is no
exception
questions we're asking right now before
we look at the data
is this the last wave we don't know uh
what will the winter look like we're not
yet sure
how much more do we need to vaccinate
quite a bit but we're not totally sure
many other questions as well let's start
with cases since the daily delta variant
peak of about a hundred and sixty seven
thousand cases per day the united states
is now down thirty nine percent in daily
average cases to about a hundred and two
thousand per day
outrageously high
but as more and more people get
vaccinated cases will mean less and less
dr isaac bogash last week told us but
we're not there yet and for now
39 percent
daily case reduction is a very good
thing
in terms of deaths in general you know
this by now rule of thumb deaths follow
cases by three to four weeks deaths are
continuing to do so uh death's now down
about 20 percent per day
from their delta peak
the delta peak was about 1900 deaths per
day we're now down to about 1600 deaths
per day still a really high number
remember that a typical flu season is
about 36 000 deaths a year that's like a
hundred deaths a day
so right now
we're at 16 times a typical flu season's
daily deaths 16 times that's an
interesting metric by the way to compare
when we think about the relative risk of
death from covid when we're out there
how does this compare to a flu season
over the course of a year and the truth
is
it's not really like this because your
36 000 flu deaths are concentrated
during flu season that's why we call it
flu season but on average a hundred flu
deaths a day is what the u.s sees in a
year we're now at 1600 coveted deaths
per day
globally we are seeing cases continuing
down
about 35 since the delta peak and then
of course global deaths as well have
peaked at about 10 300 a day those are
now down to about 7 000 global deaths a
day that's a reduction of about a third
31 to be exact in daily global deaths so
that's good
now how about vaccination well as we
talked about last week or the week
before
the u.s is getting embarrassed the u.s
is rapidly declining in terms of the
percentage of people vaccinated in the
u.s
compared to other countries particularly
compared to other so-called rich
countries take a look at this
the
leaders in vaccinated percentage are the
united arab emirates tiny country
followed by portugal which has 10
million people chile spain singapore
uruguay canada denmark china ireland
italy finland france japan uk brazil
germany
then you get to the united states in
vaccinated percentage just ahead of
turkey
and just ahead of mexico
what happened to us
we had all the vaccines earlier than
anyone
and we just can't do it people aren't
getting the vaccine it's horrifying
what's going on it's embarrassing what's
going on and we've talked about it so
much
and then lastly
the global vaccination effort overall
has also slowed down globally we had
gotten up to
about 45 million vaccines per day around
the world we're now down to roughly half
of that about 23 million vaccine doses
per day
if you look at the global population
that means each day
we're vaccinating
0.29 percent of the global population
call it 0.3
just under a third of one percent of the
world
is getting a dose each day
getting that back up to 45 million doses
a day even 50 60 million doses a day
would be absolutely huge but the good
news
no thanks to the deniers no thanks to
the anti-vaxxers and those spreading the
disinformation and misinformation
case is down significantly death's also
down let's hope it continues we'll check
in next week and hope that the numbers
are looking even better hey i'm going to
show you some stunning video
of republican senator lindsey graham
being brutally booed for saying
you should think about getting that
vaccine
this happened to trump and i'll remind
you of that daily beast reporting
republicans shout down lindsey graham
for pushing the vaccine
this is from our friend will summer
who's been a guest on the program before
who writes senator lindsey graham was
booed by republican activists saturday
after he suggested they should consider
taking the coronavirus vaccine
making him the latest prominent
republican to face a backlash from the
party's grassroots over the vaccine
speaking at a county republican event in
somerville south carolina
graham said he received the vaccine and
encouraged audience members to take it
as well
graham cited statistics showing most
patients are unvaccinated and the crowd
only got more angry let's look at this
video we're going to look at the trump
video as well here's lindsay
and listen to the crowd
if you hadn't had the vaccine you want
to think about getting it because you're
my age
[Applause]
it's actually quite quite stunning
they're told just think about it they
don't even want to do that it's actually
emblematic of this republican party
92 of the people in the hospitals in
south carolina are vaccinated
they don't believe them
they at least claim not to believe him
he says most people in the hospital are
invited no
no
i'm with you i'm with you on let's don't
mandate it right i'm with you that is
probably unconstitutional but i am not
going to legitimize what i think is the
truth the truth is
unvaccinated i'm going to lose my job in
60 days you got to stop it now okay so
this guy's screaming
this gentleman although i don't really
know if he's a gentleman this guy
says he's going to lose his job in 60
days if he doesn't get vaccinated he
wants lindsay to stop it
from the us government the navy yeah so
i'm waving
so i just i just
okay i'm a veteran too how many of you
have taken uh
measles shots
[Applause]
so lindsay tries another approach how
many of you have been vaccinated against
measles and the crowd is prepared
they're prepared they say well but
that's not the same military in the
military
they can say you gotta get vaccinated i
think that's a dumb idea you know why we
should be driving people away from
serving
like if you're a health care worker yeah
we have plenty of soldiers and you don't
want to get vaccinated
why do you want to get people to quit
being nurses
i trust you to make a decision good for
you
so are you against the vaccine
no
the half the crowd says yes half the
crowd says no
that's where i left
how do we stop it
uh you're gonna have to get somebody
yeah so that guy is completely unhinged
so um there's looney lindsay uh getting
he's trying to not be loony he's trying
to be sensible lindsay and it doesn't go
well this is what happens when the
monster you created turns against you
here's a reminder of when it happened to
trump this was at a rally not long ago
remember this guy's this was wild
three days less than nine months and
it's great and you know what i believe
totally in your freedoms i do agree you
got to do what you have to do
i recommend taking the vaccines i did it
it's good take the vaccines but
you go that's okay that's all right
you got your freedoms
but i happen to take the vaccine
if it doesn't work you'll be the first
to know okay
i'll call up alabama i'll say hey you
know what
but it is working
but uh you do they do not like it you
built this monster and now it is biting
the owner's head off the creator's head
off
um folks this is increasingly a
republican virus you know remember that
image from earlier this week
the last 100 coveted deaths have mostly
been in trumplandia i i showed you this
earlier in the week you look at a map of
the last hundred thousand coveted deaths
it looks like the map of where they
voted for trump most heavily um the the
strategy the approach here seems to be
owning the liberals by getting coveted
and dying or something like that they
believe they're proving a point in this
way
and at this point people like lindsey
graham who's cuckoo but slightly less
cuckoo than some of the others he seems
to realize we gain nothing by not
getting vaccinated just our voters die
at a greater rate than their voters and
that's probably not good for elections
it's probably not good for economies
it's not good for anything um it has
become
uh a bizarre
it i mean can is it a pyrrhic victory
in the sense that they don't get
vaccinated but then some of them die and
it's a win but you're sustaining a loss
and that people are dying i don't know
what to call it maybe just dumb maybe we
don't need to go uh and try to be more
sophisticated than what it calls for
maybe it's just dumb and bad a bad idea
uh but they turned on on lindsay just
like they did on donald trump reminder
tuesday october 19th we're doing a live
viewer town hall
um everybody can participate it will be
streamed live on the new youtube channel
that's the pacman live youtube channel
you can find it at youtube.com
pacmanlive or davidpakman.compacmanlive
6pm eastern
tuesday october 19th
everybody's welcome to call in we will
take call after call
and members will get priority so why not
sign up at joinpakman.com one of our
sponsors is blinkist who's been
supporting the david pakman show longer
than any other sponsor blinkist is the
app that lets you listen to or read an
entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes blinkist is the way to absorb
those books you can't make time for
blinkist takes top non-fiction titles
pulls out the book's key takeaways and
insights and gives it to you in the form
of a text or audio explainer that you
can consume in 15 minutes with blinkist
now you actually do have time to learn
about all the things you've been wanting
to tackle on the blinkist app i just
listened to this is your mind on plants
by the great michael pollan
super interesting the history of
caffeine and so many other things
blinkist has you covered on podcast 2.
blinkist takes long episodes of popular
podcasts and distills them into audio
you can listen to in 15 minutes with
blinkist you can become knowledgeable
about so many different things you can
have conversations with people about
more topics blinkist makes you more
well-rounded try blinkist for free and
get 25 off a subscription go to
blinkist.com
david pakman the link is down below
so you probably didn't know this but
this program is mostly funded by viewers
like you listeners like you who sign up
for the membership program on our
website we do an extra show every day
for our members i would love for you
to join the membership ranks and you can
do so at joinpacman.com
i want to talk about comedian and actor
russell brand in this segment now i'm
not going to do the lazy he's an
anti-vaccine nut sort of thing that's
been floating around there have been
some articles written that straight up
say russell brand is anti-vaxx i find it
lazy quite frankly
there is a daily beast article called
comedian russell brand has become a
powerful
voice for anti-vaxxers which comes maybe
a little closer to the reality of what's
going on
and the way we're going to look at some
clips we're going to look at a lot of
different things the way that i
characterize this is that russell brand
is definitely dancing around on the
topic of vaccination
he's asking questions and making
suggestions all in ways that encourage
vaccine hesitancy or skepticism without
like really explicitly taking an
anti-vaccine position now one can make
the argument
that doing it the way he's doing it
might be more pernicious than straight
up just doing anti-vaxx propaganda i
don't know what his intentions are and
we'll talk about that at the end
we'll look at the material first but
what's clear is that whatever he's been
doing it has worked well to build an
audience
and in particular around these sort of
contrarian ideas as we might call them
and that may play a role in how he's
choosing to frame issues maybe he's
being encouraged to do this stuff
because it's doing well i don't know
let's start with the evolution and we're
going to hit kind of a few different
points and go from there uh here is
russell brand um
many times talking about how he is
neutral about everything and just sort
of look into everything
he has no opinion or advice for you
about covet or vaccines or treatments
he's neutral let's take a listen i am
switzerland when it comes to this
subject no view at all i am merely a
floating series of molecules spores in
space that through the spike protein got
attached to something now i'm completely
neutral you can do your own research
into the impact of coronavirus and i
would suggest that you look beyond the
mainstream media into the impact of
vaccines and the efficacy of vaccines
and make your own decisions i have no
opinion i'm not offering any advice or
suggestions or even opinions around the
treatment of kovid just measuring and
judging the conversation that takes
place around it okay
so
maybe it's good to be neutral sometimes
i guess but the really important
takeaway here is neutrality is not
objectivity neutrality and objectivity
are two different things if i say i'm
neutral between water being necessary
for human life or water being the
biggest scam on earth that humans don't
really need to live
i'm staking out a position of neutrality
but there's nothing objective about it
i'm just completely wrong i'm not
adhering to the facts in my neutrality
i'm neutral but i'm completely wrong
so that's one reason to always be
skeptical about loudly professed
neutrality because neutrality and
objectivity are two different things so
let's now look at russell brand's first
statement that i could find about kovid
this was back in march of 2020 march
13th of 2020 i believe
this was just a few days after trump
made the big speech about
we're closing this we're closing that
and there's a virus and it's already
sort of like a little bit woo-woo and
starting to this is the type of stuff
that lends itself
to people
looking to you to justify their own
skepticism and disbelief even about
things you're not directly talking about
take a look
my personal take on it is it's a
reminder that reality
lies below the surface the deepest
realities cannot be seen
you know
microbiology can at any point
alter the game and that's what about
what's happening even beneath that held
in fields of invisible energy
so i suppose you know
so it's you know wash your hands yeah be
sensible but significantly remember how
often we live in concepts and constructs
that are not real and are not beneficial
so you know i guess wash your hands but
at the same time you know we can't
really see a lot of this stuff and
i don't know it's it's starting to get a
little bit squishy okay
then we cut to this year where it's
really ramped up as his follower base
has grown this type of stuff is ramped
up
this is now we're going from last march
13 to this september 13 just under a
month ago
russell brand says the problem of kovid
is small
compared to that of the vaccine mandates
so now we're really getting into some
meaty stuff for the anti-vax crowd
whatever russell's view is of vaccines
per se the problem of coronavirus is
small compared to the problem of the
framework that we are discovering holds
it a framework of disdain contempt and
conflict as long as we forget
fundamental basic values kindness open
communication tolerance if we forget
those things there is no society worth
saving no matter what you believe now
this is one of those things where like
yeah kindness okay sure sure uh but the
problem of covet is still a big problem
and uh that this idea of
this this uh minimizing
again whatever his views are it feeds
into it feeds into the people
who want to say we don't need the
vaccine or the mandates are definitely
bad or whatever now here's a little bit
of a break into something that also is
part of this
um russell spoke with tim poole tim
poole is this guy we've interviewed him
before he said he used to be on the left
or he sort of still claims to be 90 of
his content is anti-democratic i've
talked to him about it you know no no it
should not come as a shock to many of
you that um uh he said he voted for
trump in 2020 so this is another one of
these like i'm sort of i'm on the left
i'm kind of an enlightened centrist
really it just seems that like at least
you're mostly doing content that
criticizes the left and you're voting
for trump okay so russell brings on tim
poole and they do this shtick about
we're very close to civil war very very
close to civil war and this is a trope
now the the the left is ripping us apart
we're they're pushing us to the brink of
civil war you used to say more um
frequently at least as as i'm aware that
you felt that i think i guess in the
final days of trump that america was on
the brink of some kind of civil war and
i still do
do yeah
yeah there's a uh but there there's been
polling data that i think may uh uh you
know evolve that opinion notably there
was a yougov data that show i think it
was yougov that uh there's five regions
in the united states there's the
northeastern there's the southern
there's the heartland there's the the
west and the mountain regions
and in each region there was a large
plurality of people who wanted to secede
from the union and form their own
regional governments essentially if you
if you uh normalize for population in
each by each state i did the math you
end up with 37.2 percent of the us
population wanting the country to break
apart okay now i don't exactly know the
normalization he's referring to i know
what normalization means i remember we
talked about that that poll
i don't exactly know
i don't know if he means maybe he
doesn't even mean normalization he just
has extrapolated i think maybe tim
doesn't know the difference between
extrapolating and normalizing what he's
not mentioning is that those
disproportionately wanting to secede are
southern republicans and
this entire civil war narrative that he
and some others have been pushing
imp sometimes explicitly sometimes
implicitly i will will grant that it's
not always explicit is that the left's
intolerance or unwillingness to do
whatever is what's pushing us to the
brink of civil war
um
the reality is that
you know the closest thing that we got
to a civil war starting that i can
recall in the last many years was the
january sixth insurrection it was
exclusively trump is who did it and even
if you look at secession and secession
and civil war are two different things
um it's disproportionately southern
republicans who want to do it and this
is the type of stuff that that russell
platforms i would say it's not
responsible platforming in that he's not
really ready to rebut the substance of
what's being said okay then russell
brand shares a tweet
which seems to be telling people
how to get around covid safety measures
during his comedy tour okay this is
called the 33
tour
russell brand tweeted this and it's 33
tour info and it says
there are some misunderstandings around
the venue requirements for the 33 tour
this should address the concerns we've
seen expressed
no venue requires you to be double
vaccinated so that's sort of like you
can just go and get one and not the
second and you're going to be able to
get in
most venues do not ask for any
certification again saying
it's kind of the honor system at a lot
of places you can probably go without
being vaccinated some require proof of a
negative test and then saying if you
have a ticket that requires you to have
a test and you don't want one will move
your ticket to another venue it might
require travel so again it's it's all
kind of slippery like no one of these
things is that egregious but it's all
fomenting a particular
line of thought from the people that
follow him okay so now we'll go to a
more recent clip in this clip russell
brand suggests looking beyond the
mainstream media for information about
vaccines and what's really slippery and
squishy about this one is i'm the first
to agree you can't just trust corporate
media for everything but the implication
here is that there's this whole other
hidden truth that's not being presented
in the corporate media about vaccines
and if you're if you're aware that the
the general narrative which is accurate
is well the vaccines are quite safe and
quite effective
if you're being told there's some other
completely different narrative without
him telling you anything anti-vaxx per
se you start to think wow what what am i
not being told let's take a listen do
your own research into the impact of
coronavirus and i would suggest that you
look beyond the mainstream media into
the impact of vaccines and the efficacy
of vaccines and make your own decisions
i have no opinion right he has no he
still has no opinion but again it's this
idea that you may not be getting told
all the things you should be getting
told and you've got to look for it here
is russell brand then on vaccine
passports which he equates to
totalitarianism
it's very interesting how this
particular issue is being treated with a
very specific and one might argue
totalitarian
mindset where else where our cultures
are built on principles of individualism
like you know well you're an individual
you're responsible for your own life
you're responsible if you're in prison
or if you can't make a go of life
yourself that's your fault that's your
responsibility so it's being regarded
uniquely as opposed to someone like me
that's skeptical and sometimes downright
cynical about government the agenda of
governments the relationships of
government with big business
something like this
makes me concerned about the direction
we're heading so again it's just vaguely
alluding to the idea of freedom freedom
is not anybody requiring a vaccine for
sure that that's absolutely not it um
and then this is just where it starts to
get really weird russell says he saw a
dead fish in the river
and that seems like a bad omen from the
standpoint of totalitarian vaccine
passports whatever your views on the
pandemic where it came from how it came
to be here
what the impact of it is on a sort of
individual social and cultural level the
fact is that
now the response to it does align with
some people's opinions about uh
government agenda i.e further control
further invasion further um
regulation of your life their very idea
that you might not be able to attend a
public event
without
showing a possible that concerns me
other people might say well we've all
got national insurance numbers and stuff
like that
i don't know man i like the other day i
was uh on the river y and i saw dead
fish in that river like you know and
like when you see things that feel like
an indication of something foreboding
it's i think foolish not to respond to
it so that's that's strange okay that
now it starts to get really strange
um and then just to give you kind of
like just a final tour through this here
is russell
um saying
russiagate quote russiagate was cooked
up by the clintons which is becoming
very popular among the right the world
moves so fast there's almost no time for
history it seems like years ago that we
were hearing that trump was colluding
with russia they wouldn't have won the
election without russia that his whole
presidency was a kind of putin plot well
there's now serious evidence that it was
the clinton campaign and hillary clinton
acolytes that were directly involved in
the generation of what has proven to be
a conspiracy untrue think about how much
media you watched so this this is just a
you know
straight up right wing talking point and
then lastly
here he says vaccine fact-checkers may
not be trustworthy you have to be
open-minded and
open-eyed about the reality of the
information you're being presented
elsewhere in another one of our videos
we talk about the sort of appetite for
apartheid like people have not been
vaccinated should be pushed this way you
know i don't have a strong opinion about
what you should do with your life you
should be free i should be free we
should be free to talk we should be free
to disagree that what i have concerns
about are the legislation and regulation
around the way that information is
communicated information is censored
because i want to feel like i can trust
people i want to feel like i can trust
the media i want to feel like i trust
the government i don't enjoy seeing they
do actually i do enjoy sitting here
doing this but like i feel that the
systems themselves are so dependent on
their own sort of corrupt spiraling
interrelationship that it's not possible
for it to operate freely i don't even
think there's anyone evil at facebook or
at cdc or whatever i just think there's
just a big sort of tidal rolling of
profiteering that's so sort of embedded
that people can't see that it's
happening it's bigger than them that's
what a system is a system is like we're
all a set of nodes operating in a
broader trajectory a broader telos and
none of us can sort of like sort of step
outside and go hang on what's going on
is this the best way to do things and if
you can't see a situation like a fact
checker being funded by people whose
chat check facts it's checking it is
quite odd
[Laughter]
then then you're not open-minded enough
so anyway even the fact-checkers maybe
cannot uh cannot be trusted okay so so
what's the bottom line here the
difficulty here is that this is not like
straight-up anti-vaxx and calling
russell brand anti-vaxx is is lazy it's
not it doesn't really encompass it
there's no real single anti-vaccine clip
he's dancing he's encouraging anti-vax
people to become more anti-vaxx not
saying he's doing it on purpose but he
is
um the videos he pumps out all have the
same sort of like tinge which we're
gonna look at
uh problems with the vaccine studies
against the vaccine famous proponent of
the vaccine who you can't trust and he
hints one way while claiming to be
neutral but clearly he's not objective i
mean just we'll we'll look at some of
his uh clip titles here
um uh oh the wuhan lab leak debate just
got even something else
um
uh are the uh wait hold on let's look at
which are the vaccine related ones how
big pharma ceos plan to profit from
keeping you maybe it's sick
can we really trust vaccine fact
checkers
thought biden couldn't sink any lower
think again
vaccine apartheid don lemons covet
bombshell
uh good science or irresponsible this is
why you can't trust big pharma shocking
wuhan evidence etc it's uh vaccine
mandates and assault on your bodily uh
whatever it's actually quite similar to
the jimmy dore idea it's very similar to
what jimmy dore does fauci has no answer
study vaccines being administered
incorrectly
vac side effects reported sudden hearing
loss
vaccines cause hurricanes biden says
vaccine custard which is just a muddle
it's just you know that's kind of the
biden dementia story covid surge among
vaccinated it's the exact same type of
idea
um
a couple different things could be
happening one some individuals are just
taking their distress of the
pharmaceutical industry which we should
all have to some degree
and broadly applying it to covid and to
the vaccine in a way that maybe is well
intended but is very much misguided for
others this is a straight-up grift
i don't know which one it is for russell
brand i i genuinely don't know which
category i put him in taking
pharmaceutical skepticism too far
grift
delusional i don't know but the
evolution of russell brand is giving
significant
uh comfort so to speak and encouragement
to those already skeptical of just going
out and getting vaccinated let me know
what you think it is that's going on
with russell brand
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpacman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount joinpakman.com
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com
davidpakmanshow where you can get access
to behind the scenes videos the daily
bonus show the commercial free daily
show as well as special discounts on
merch including hats hoodies mugs and
t-shirts
you can support the show for as little
as two dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com
davidpakmanshow
so things continue to really just go
horribly wrong for facebook we talked
yesterday about
the monday outage of facebook instagram
and whatsapp we talked about the sunday
unveiling of who is this whistleblower
that released thousands of documents
about face internal facebook documents
about facebook knows about the harm
that's caused to different people uh by
its platforms francis haugen the name of
the whistleblower uh and i played
yesterday for you an interview with one
facebook executive on npr and it was
just terrible just the guy seemed shaken
by the obvious questions unable to
answer in a coherent way yesterday we
had testimony from the whistleblower
francis haugen and then afterwards we
had a very unusual interview
with facebook's vice president for
content policy monica bickert on cnn
where again
i don't know if these interviews go
horribly wrong because the people are
unprepared or because the facts simply
aren't on their side and there's really
no way to come off looking even remotely
uh coherent and sensible so first let's
start with a cnn article just quickly
outlining the takeaways from yesterday's
testimony by the facebook whistleblower
francis haugen yesterday testified
before a senate subcommittee the big
takeaways okay
facebook's mechanics further the spread
of misinformation one big takeaway
second takeaway facebook has taken
limited action to address existing
misinformation we really knew this but
again
further confirmed
facebook has misled the public about the
negative effects of its platforms on
children and teens especially young
girls despite public statements from
mark zuckerberg and others saying it's
pretty good
uh in short um internal documents show
they know about the negative effects and
facebook knows its platform enables
human exploitation so let's get to this
interview that took place this is an
interview with monica bicker vp for
content policy on facebook and it's very
similar to the one yesterday uh that i
played for you from npr here we have
video and it's deflections and just kind
of like strange not very credible
denials is a current facebook executive
monica bickert is a vice president for
content policy at facebook ms bicker
thank you so much for being here i
really appreciate it i know you just
heard that report and so i i want to get
your take on what francis hogan has said
is it true that facebook uses these
algorithms that push inflammatory
content because that drives more clicks
and engagement
it is not true
and i want to say i think there have
been a lot of mischaracterizations today
about uh what those stolen documents say
and about the work that we are doing to
keep facebook safe
but just so i'm clear just i just want
to be clear this is a key interjection
what it what specifically are you
denying who do not use you're saying
what part is not true you don't push out
inflammatory controversial content
because you know that heightens
engagement
we do the opposite in fact now that's
just now it's where it gets silly
you push out non-engaging content come
on come on it it now gets
you know i think a better way to answer
this would be to say
um unfortunately in our world
the most salacious news
is more likely to be shared by users by
users this is human nature it's not
unique to facebook i sound like a flunky
now for you know a pr person for these
companies this is not unique to facebook
we can't control the fact
that a lot of the stuff that's most
salacious that people want to share
is fake news and disinformation what we
can do however
uh is have an algorithm that will number
one label it as such and number two not
prior okay but no no we do the opposite
what you push out stuff people don't
find interesting come on if you look in
our transparency center you can actually
see
that we demote meaning we reduce the
visibility of engagement click bait and
why would we do that one big reason is
because for the long term health of our
services we want people to have a good
experience we want them to want to
continue to come back to these sites and
connect with the people they care about
what gets people coming back to the site
is that it's a source of titillating
rage inducing
fear inducing
um uh
material that's what keeps people coming
back
it would be
facebook doesn't think you know
if we keep doing this for a hundred
years then um
no no it just it doesn't work that way
for years to come do my background
hold on i have a question about that do
you deny that teenage girls are not
having a good experience on
instagram the majority of young people
on instagram are having a good
experience and that is borne out
by the documents that were stolen
including the instagram youth survey of
about 40 instagram users guys 40 users
40 4-0 on a platform that has hundreds
of millions is are there billions of
people on instagram
these were teens who were already
struggling with mental health issues and
on all of the issues the majority of
boys and girls
said that instagram either makes things
better
or doesn't have a material impact on
their experience now look forward so
hold on hold on i just want to be clear
here so hold on just one thing i'd let
you say your piece you're saying that
you do not have internal research that
shows that depression and suicidal
thoughts go up for teenage girls as do
thoughts of eating disorders
i'm saying that for the majority of
teens
that's really slippery
the question is do you have internal
data that says it's it's hurting
young kids including girls what monica
bickard says is
we have one survey that says it's not
hurting them and it's based on 40 people
because what's the truth the truth is
they have this 40-person survey that
they're pointing to and then they have
all of the other data that is exactly
what francis haugen said
but she's not talking about that it's
not it's not a denial it's just we also
have this 40 person survey that's fine
instagram and the survey that that the
stolen survey that was uh shared in the
testimony shows that the majority of
teens this was a very small survey this
is not peer-reviewed research right but
that survey has been mischaracterized
significantly because of what it
actually says and we've published it
people can go look at it for themselves
on the 12 issues for these teens who
were already struggling with mental
health issues
instagram the majority of them said
instagram either makes things better or
it doesn't have a material impact so
again now we're multiple minutes into a
40 person survey which is the only one
she wants to talk about minority how
about the minority the 13
that said that it increased suicidal
thoughts
it's important to say that i spent my
career
as a criminal prosecutor and worked a
lot on child safety so even one teenager
having a bad experience on instagram so
that's like sort of an appeal to
authority fallacy in a sense kind of
genetic fallacy that may have been what
she was doing in her previous role
that's not what she's doing now is too
many and i can tell you that the
hundreds of people at facebook who
actually do work on child safety this
former employee does not uh did not but
those who do work on child safety and
work with dozens of external academics
and child safety experts
this is our top priority and not only
who would
possibly believe that so
there's there's a few more minutes to
this interview i encourage you to check
it out um
you know
in a sense it's genuinely surprising how
poorly prepared these facebook folks
seem to be at the same time maybe this
is prepared as you can be but the facts
aren't on your side and that's
fundamentally what the problem is here
so let me know your thoughts i know
facebook has to do something they're
sort of these folks are in in a sense in
an impossible position because they have
to defend the indefensible um but this
is not i don't believe this issue is
going away anytime soon hey this is
something very very interesting
uh rioting as a family affair
a mother and son rioted together on
january 6th isn't that loving is is that
an act of love would we call it that
they've now both been arrested okay new
york mother and son arrested in theft of
pelosi's staff laptop during the capital
riot nbc news reporting that the fbi
have arrested marianne mooney rondon 55
and her son
rafael rondon 23 of watertown new york
in connection with a stolen laptop
according to court documents this is
actually out of alaska which is where
they ended up finding the computer
apparently a new york mother and son
have been charged with theft in aiding
the disappearance of a laptop belonging
to the staff of nancy pelosi during the
trump riots after the fbi initially
raided a home 4500 miles away from dc
in alaska looking for the computer the
fbi have arrested as i mentioned
marianne mooney rondon and her son
rafael rondan in connection with that
laptop used only for presentations
according to court documents both also
face other charges related to the riot
at the capitol raphael rondon also faces
possession of classic an unregistered
sawed-off shotgun both were in federal
court friday in syracuse new york
released pending further proceedings now
there's even a question you know the
trumpets have been saying these folks
are being treated so unfairly held and
sawed off shotgun
rioting at dc and they're just released
pending further proceedings if anything
it seems these folks may be treated very
lightly by the criminal justice system
so far
break into the capital
steal pelosi's laptop
sawed off shotgun charge and just walk
free pending further proceedings now
there's there's significant reform to be
done here uh but the point is the
argument that they're all being treated
disproportionately unfairly for
political reasons clearly it doesn't
apply to everybody
capital riot was well documented by
those who took part
a tip to the fbi led them to the mother
and son according to a statement of
facts documented by an fbi special agent
mooney rondon that's the mom allegedly
admitted to being in both the capital uh
the day of the riots as well as nancy
pelosi's conference room she allegedly
provided gloves or a scarf to a man to
steal the laptop without leaving
fingerprints
he asked he said give me i don't know if
it was gloves or a scarf i was wearing
and like i said he scared me the
document quotes her as saying
um there's also another interesting
thing here
that i think is relevant oh the level of
premeditation okay they want to push the
idea that everything was spur of the
moment look at this raphael rondon
that's the son told police officers that
he and mother
took the metro on january 6th quote
because i'm not taking my car into the
city which the capitol building i'm
about to break into
really undercuts the idea that this was
some kind of spur of the moment thing
they seem to be saying we at least
suspected that things were going to get
sort of crazy and so we deliberately
didn't bring the car we took public
transit instead at least some degree
there of for knowledge or premeditation
so we will we will follow this case as
we're following other cases
but mother and son mother and son can
you imagine and the stories about these
individuals i mean listen i'll i'll be
transparent
you read about many of these stories
they're just sad it's it's sad people
but that doesn't mean that they
shouldn't be held accountable and in
fact we're going to talk about that in
the next segment which is there has not
been nearly enough accountability for
the trump rioters we'll get to that
after this short break
one of our sponsors is blinkist who's
been supporting the david pakman show
longer than any other sponsor blinkist
is the app that lets you listen to or
read an entire non-fiction book in just
15 minutes blinkist is the way to absorb
those books you can't make time for
blinkist takes top non-fiction titles
pulls out the book's key takeaways and
insights and gives it to you in the form
of a text or audio explainer that you
can consume in 15 minutes with blinkist
now you actually do have time to learn
about all the things you've been wanting
to tackle on the blinkist app i just
listened to this is your mind on plants
by the great michael pollan
super interesting the history of
caffeine and so many other things
blinkist has you covered on podcast two
blinkist takes long episodes of popular
podcasts and distills them into audio
you can listen to in 15 minutes with
blinkist you can become knowledgeable
about so many different things you can
have conversations with people about
more topics blinkist makes you more
well-rounded try blinkist for free and
get 25 off a subscription go to
blinkist.com
david pakman the link is down below
my friends they aren't even pretending
anymore that they don't want more
violence they're threatening it openly
they're telling us
you know we might have to do more
violent stuff i'm about to play video
for you a former trump strategist and a
former breitbart propagandist steve
bannon
steve bannon says
we aren't going to have 4 000 shock
troops ready to go we're going to have
20 000 shock troops ready to go so that
we can take control of this country
they aren't even hiding it anymore let's
take a look at the video this is from uh
steve bannon's program
uh the war room
on real america's voice listen to this
the opposition particularly opposition
elite and all their sword boys and
everything in silicon valley media it's
not a big part of the population and
they understand that
they understand it
the thing they fear
is the righteous indignation
of the working class
in this country
and now they're seeing it and that's why
they're in meltdown the story i gave
this talk to these appointees and here's
what i said we're winning big in 2022
we're going to win big in 2024 we need
to get ready now
right we control this country we got to
start acting like it
and one way we're going to act like it
we're not gonna have four thousand ready
to go we're gonna have twenty thousand
ready to go and we're gonna pick the
four thousand best and the most ready in
every single department
and that's when we really start to
deconstruct the administrative state
that's talk afc packing oh it's trying
to destroy no no no no we're trying to
get an fda worse
shock troops on standby we control this
country
we have to start acting like it
and uh as zack petrizzo reported
joe ben uh steve bannon
continued by talking about the
importance of spiritual warfare to his
audience
to defeat the enemy
this is exactly what the fbi should be
investigating this this is exactly the
type of thing
that will rile people up
and get them ready to do horrible things
again
he's essentially calling for
a um
so i mean is militia even the right word
he's calling for
a people to be on standby to forcibly
take slash remain in power
now i do want to sort of turn this
around and take the take it as an
opportunity to make a different point
if there aren't more
see if there aren't more and more
serious consequences for the january 6th
rioters
that will also implicitly encourage them
to try again and to go crazier
this guy was the chief strategist for
the president of the united states
this is not ending anytime soon it's
been less than a year since trump helped
by
senators members of congress
the
maga people
people like steve bannon they encouraged
they incited
they pushed
for an attempt
to try to take the election from the guy
who actually won it who was joe biden
now
some of the dupes
some of the patsies that's really what
they are
they've faced repercussions to some
degree
a couple have been sentenced some are in
the middle of trials we talked earlier
about the mother and son who were
arrested
but none of the people who instigated it
in congress has lost the seat now we
haven't had elections yet i understand
that we'll see if they lose seats but
the point is
it's not clear whether they will really
have and suffer electoral consequences
for their inciting for the fomenting of
what happened on january 6. so you know
we saw the lone wolf recently who tried
to burn down a democratic office in
texas things like that as long as the
right
continues to at a at a structural level
push this type of violent rhetoric
uh they're going to continue uh through
this kind of stochastic terrorism that
we've talked about before
creating these individual incidents the
individuals may face consequences some
may not some may plead out we don't know
yet
but are they really lone wolves when you
have this entire partisan apparatus
right-wing media apparatus a strong
contingent of republicans in the house
and senate when they're encouraging it
are they really even lone wolves anymore
even if the the physical act is one they
carry out by themselves as far as we
know
uh there's this entire apparatus kind of
vaguely encouraging this behavior if not
specifically now some are asking how is
what steve bannon is saying not
treasonous treason is is sort of
specific in terms of its legal
definition article three section three
of the constitution
which says treason against the u.s shall
consist only in levying war against them
or in adhering to their enemies giving
them aid and comfort the key is that
treason means going against the us and
americans as a whole
this is all kind of tinged enough about
going against a political party and a
movement
that it's probably not sufficient to
meet the definition of treason it's more
like a
a seditious conspiracy to overthrow
um the the particular government that
there is or something like that
um
but it doesn't make it any more morally
acceptable let's make that completely
clear so
we're going to see more of this action
in real life because we're continuing to
see more of the rhetoric on right-wing
media
and you know going back to my earlier
segment on russell brand without
straight up being anti-vaxx and russell
brand probably isn't anti-vaxx
he has kind of threaded a line
that is asking the right questions as
they love to say
to push people
to become anti-vaxx on their own if
they're not already and if and if they
are already it just kind of encourages
them and ingrains them in those beliefs
this is very similar with what we're
seeing with uh tucker calling about a
real insurrection might be warranted
steve bannon talking about 20 000 shock
troops and the like this is real stuff
and it has real consequences in the real
world i went back and forth about
whether to cover this next story and i
decided to ultimately
and there's a few points i want to make
because there are kind of some bad takes
coming from this story so the story that
has surfaced is hey trump's finances are
collapsing well what's the evidence well
forbes has this writ a list of the
richest 400 americans that they publish
and donald trump is off the list for the
first time in a really really really
long time so donald trump's financial
situation is suffering the article on
forbes says donald trump is worth an
estimated 2.5 billion dollars
leaving him 400 million dollars short of
the cut off to make this year's forbes
400 list of america's richest people the
real estate mogul is just as wealthy as
he was a year ago
when he was number 339 on the ranking
but he's down 600 million since the
start of the pandemic tech stocks
cryptos and other assets have thrived in
the covet era but big city properties
making up the bulk of trump's fortune
have languished knocking the former
president out of the nation's most
exclusive club
um they have this chart showing trump's
ranking
in terms of uh wealth
and uh there was a point in the uh late
90s rather where trump was like roughly
in the top 100 wealthiest then in the
early 2000s he kind of got up close to
the 50th wealthiest and then it's been
declining since 2015. so there there's a
few different things here that i think
are important because there's there's
some confusion about sort of what this
means
we have to balance uh on the one hand
it really shouldn't be insanely
profitable to be president now every
president is gonna get at this point
they're gonna get a nice book deal at
minimum for sure
but remember that donald trump still
made 1.6 billion dollars over the four
years that he was president now he said
he was going to be out of his businesses
blind trust even though he didn't really
understand what that is the big
presentation with a stack of paper
that was legal paper that we don't even
know what what it did
he made a killing during his presidency
so did his children trump still made 1.6
billion during his four years
at the same time
the presidency
did some damage to trump's brand i mean
there's probably
close to half the country on principle
wouldn't go to a trump hotel at this
point in time and so trump's still
filthy rich
he's just not quite as rich relative to
this group of the richest americans
remember he's still as wealthy as he was
a year ago in terms of dollars but
because trump is real estate heavy and a
lot of these other rich people are more
diversified cryptos stocks other things
trump in ranking has fallen behind so
you you
a lot of people are wanting to take just
like a black and white view oh so well
if he's no longer in the richest 400
clearly he didn't rape and pillage for
his personal wealth while he was
president well no he benefited greatly
from being president foreign dignitaries
coming and staying at his hotels in
order to ingratiate themselves with him
etc
he still made 1.6 billion during his
presidency
his kids made a ton of money despite
being sort of loosely or less loosely
associated with the administration i
don't need the guy to be poor
but let's not allow him
importantly to skirt responsibility and
the due process of others because he's
rich when it comes to saying no this
person i don't have to testify in this
case and i don't have to provide
documents in that case and all this
other stuff because he used to be
president or be or because he was
president at the time
and the issue of exactly how rich he is
relative to others is less important so
to some degree many of trump's
businesses are struggling trump makes a
ton of money from other things as well
licensing and different things
a lot of his hotels aren't doing so well
the value property values some have
suffered there's no doubt about that
but the right is pointing this and
saying you guys on the left were saying
trump was taking advantage of his
position to make money
and he didn't really make money no he
did he still made 1.6 billion it's just
relative to the other 400 richest
americans
he comparatively fell slightly behind
400 million a year while president is
your full-time job uh is still very very
solid now the other question is
has he been honest about his wealth all
along did he ever really have i think at
one point he was claiming three or four
billion
who the hell knows that's another
question altogether he's not an honest
guy that we know but let's not read more
into this than what we actually should
which is trump did extremely well while
being president even though he said it
was bad for him financially to be
president 1.6 billion is pretty good
but some other even richer mostly men
but people
um did even better than trump that's
fundamentally what it comes down to we
don't really need to read too much more
into it we have a voicemail number and
that number is 2192 david p hey this is
kind of a sad voicemail long time
adversarial caller troy york who calls
in under fake names all the time
he left the voi his voicemails are
increasingly disjointed which i know
says a lot for troy york um he left one
where it's not even really clear what
point he's making or what he's talking
about it's kind of sad in a way the
trolling has gotten even less coherent
david pakman covered and the fake
numbers are provided and manipulated to
go after republican
politicians there's no evidence of that
whatsoever plain simple as we see with
his garbage
with the media constantly attacking ron
desantis
in florida remember
florida is reporting numbers under
republican governor ron desantis the
idea that the left is reporting fake
florida numbers to make him look bad
it's the desantis department of health
and desantis appointees that are all
involved in managing the numbers that
are reported this is an incoherent
allegation and uh this is ryan bosworth
i'm calling this is not ryan bosworth
this is troy york of course florida
jacksonville florida and um
if you're so smart why don't you run for
governor in florida or um non-sequitur
completely irrelevant
why don't you run for president in 2024
wasn't born in the u.s not eligible to
be president
what a bizarre and sad downfall of troy
york he's some we haven't played a troy
york voicemail for a while but he's
sometimes leaving
three four five voicemails a day
all under supposedly different names
some of them criticizing me for things i
haven't said i think he's confusing this
show with a different show uh but a sad
state of affairs for troy york hope he
uh hope he does better we've got a great
bonus show for you today
there's a hospital that is saying it
will be denying transplants to
unvaccinated people
in almost all situations can they do
this legally
and what are the details we will discuss
also the u.s federal government
has ordered google to identify
every single person who searched
a sexual assault victim's name address
and telephone number on the internet
they want to do this for investigative
purposes is it legal though we will talk
about it and a third sandy hook parent
has won a defamation lawsuit against
conspiracy theorist alex jones from
infowars we'll talk about the
repercussions and what is going to
happen next all of those stories and
more on today's bonus show
get instant access
to the bonus show by becoming a member
at joinpacman.com or becoming a patron
at patreon.com slash david packard
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription by going to blinkist.com
david pakman